welcome to occasionally awesome episode
182 this is a very special occasionally
awesome our guest is the teeb we hang
out we talk about his new upcoming album
which you should get on all things
comedy and iTunes and Spotify and
wherever you can purchase and stream
albums and we get into a discussion
about comedy in life and there is a very
special announcement about occasionally
awesome at the end of the episode we
encourage all of our loyal listeners to
hang out listen and enjoy
okay then you ran it did you say hi
don't know I mean I just looked at him I
do that thing ready to stare at Pete
I've you know saying look give steering
problem like I definitely do I just lock
in and I can't again undersized get
wider so you're definitely staring I
just and I eventually I just like go
full mannequin and just sit there and
staring at somebody well really screwed
me was that I didn't start wearing
glasses till like two years ago mmm and
so in the sunglass problem in my ray
bans are like just like light and dark
enough that I can wear them inside and
not tell if I'm you know if I'm wearing
long enough I don't know which glasses I
have on I constantly with these glasses
on get caught looking at tits oh yeah
and i'm like why she oh that's right i'm
wearing those shoes what's right at
nick's problem oh it's me i'm a perv oh
she oh it's fear her problem is fear
yeah however staring at her fear of rape
yeah it's not even trying to hide it
yeah I'm hitting the tuning fork of fear
no no she just looks at me and I just go
whoops I just when they look at me I
just go ya know what I've always thought
is so funny is when God I'll see like
two guys standing somewhere and like a
pretty woman will walk by and they both
stopped talking cuz they're a pretty
woman walks by they both sucked i just
casually bobbing their head like there's
music playing but there's no music
playing they're always late mmhmm yeah
but don't really look at her it's like
it's like this weird like hey I like
music in general because like bite their
lips are like uh you're probably talking
about something other priming a rape
joke before the girl walked by I got a
decision did you two do but there's
another one two were two guys are
talking and like their body language is
one way and then right as the girl
passes by like the one guy he kind of
like takes it all down a little bit and
then when she walks by you see the guy
way to beat and then like look to see
your ass because the guy was definitely
like dude you gotta see this chick so
but the walk by like that's my problem
cuz my the girl I'm seeing is like a
rien insane body oh yeah so now I'm like
super like I'm just looking at guys like
I like I
yeah stir up like yeah yeah to where
they're not checking it out well it's in
it you can't not yeah yeah so I kind of
have to do like dude don't let me catch
you do it do it do what you gotta do i
understand what it is to be a guy but
like don't like cuz I'm always worried
there's people gonna say something I'm
gonna have to start chipping t yeah
wouldn't that be you I let that moment
it's so like oh man what am I gonna do
yeah I wanted I gotta carry one of those
black Jack's with me yeah yeah like duh
then I mean this in a complementary way
but like my girlfriend's body is like
NBA player kryptonite yeah yeah you know
I mean it was like I'm gonna find myself
in a situation I'm like oh yeah they're
gonna rape her and beat me up okay like
do I have to fight Cuba Gooding jr.
right now god damn it actually that is
the fear yeah that's the fear I don't
think we've ever done a podcast at night
it's not night it's just 5 p.m. in the
winter in la it gets dark it like three
well i guess like the night mean in the
darkness in the darkness yeah yeah it is
five o'clock yeah it is weird how it
starts getting like that and it makes me
tired yeah yet I could go to bed in an
hour yeah I probably will yeah this is
gonna bit here okay yeah let's just
sleep in a pile like puppy right um yeah
it does make me tired too ya can't help
but and now it's like raining it's like
and by the way I only came from like I
was kind of I like Joe's pizza like
right by the store a little bit easy for
30 minute over Wow with more than that
because I got in it at four thirty miles
like oh I'm gonna actually be like 5-10
minutes early and it took me almost 40
minutes I'm traffic in a little bit
right now some gridlock in the Midwest
arese cuz it's like go [ __ ] yourselves
all through a little bit of rain a'carly
barely raining it is everyone in their
cars are acting like I gotta get home
before it starts it took me 25 minutes
to get home from the gym which normally
takes about 12 because of traffic 15
minutes when it rained and I'm no one
knows what to do anymore yeah like it
starts raining and they're like what's
this circle in front of me I'm like it's
your steering wheel figure out yeah I I
feel like a sense of urgency when it
starts raining I'm like I have to get
home inside my home and hide like I've
just like
get away from it this is good Heidi like
watch a movie whether yeah we don't know
like outside of Los Angeles to assume
every I assume nobody in Los Angeles
listens to any of our podcasts and then
like the rest of the world does you can
buy a car when you buy or lease a new
car in Los Angeles a lot of people to
know this you can get a thousand dollars
off if you go no I don't need windshield
wipers I'll take the thousand dollars
off and just take the version with no
windshield wipers what can you really do
be awesome now would be close it would
be cool but I mean how often you use
windshield wipers in Los Angeles I've
never used ice a year yeah maybe yeah I
got a new car I definitely didn't know
which way to turn them on down or up
because I had drove for two months
without using them exactly yeah yeah
like are then left or right yeah lights
are on sorry yeah yeah so yeah it's
basically the end of the world here in
la if you guys are listening from
somewhere else [ __ ] is this c 9
degrees nine degrees with a light rain
yeah Trump's president the Cubs won the
World Series and it's raining in Los
Angeles it's time to sell you know what
I was I laugh like to myself today cuz
like I get those little notifications on
my screen from the news mmm and like and
for the last unit two weeks it'll be
like Steve benen something something
something has been appointed to you know
chief of staff it's always a name and
then the appointment yeah so today I got
the notification that said Dylann roof
who killed nine people in charleston
south carolina in in my head i completed
the sounds like has been appointed
Secretary of Defense orizaba ka and
nothing surprising in health and human
services yeah exactly yeah he appointed
he's gonna maybe point Sylvester
Stallone as and this is I'm not dogging
stars ahead of the Red National down for
the Arts what to be fair had that
position in the past that's like up baby
I don't actually know I don't think i
don't know i don't know at all anybody
but sylvester stallone is a massive art
collector like massive knows a [ __ ] ton
yeah but why not get someone who does
that for a living I don't know cuz they
probably he probably thinks are all they
probably all hate him that's what people
always say when they go like when you
turn on the news and you're like why
Sean Penn talking about Haiti and they
go well it's done like a lot of work
there and he knows and it's like but so
if people who do that for
living yeah yeah but I think like when
they're on TV talking about it like I
see some like you know who knows who
this person is looks like a high school
substitute teacher talking about stuff I
just turn it received and like I'll miss
you disposals talking about I mean maybe
some people do stay tuned but then other
people go like oh what Sean Penn doing
Osama real issues and then you turn
change channel anyway yeah yeah yeah
either way it's a channel I have that
same reaction like shut up dummy I don't
want to hear from you what they should
yet what they should do Sean Penn should
come on with with like you know a
professional in whatever field and just
sit next to me go yeah gonna point ago I
yeah yeah i agree i learned that from
him yeah he's loved Sean Penn they're
really don't like you this guy cmart
like pointing at his buddy I think I've
seen celebrities do that like maybe like
like Ben Affleck where they kind of go
on a show with somebody like well I'm
I'm excited to be here to talk about
this doctor's book yeah yeah cuz they
know they're not no one's gonna pay
attention to it otherwise yeah it's
basically they're producing yeah yes but
they're producing information or the
possibility of being altruistic yeah
have you any of you guys seen that um
Oliver Stone's americ don't hold
American history thing or what is I
haven't clicked on it oh no I haven't
started yet but I want to it's good
really good okay oh really it's pretty
much like first of all it's so much
information and it's one of those things
were like you know this guy forever has
just been like smoking pot and like pot
beating off to conspiracy theory right
right and he goes I think I can tell all
these stories in nine hours wow you know
I was basically the history of the of
America seemed the way the rest of the
world sees it not the way we were told
it right you know a lot of it's like oh
yeah that's right but in a lot of it
you're like oh [ __ ] that's how that
really that's a good way down yeah yeah
cuz the rest of the world sees us so
differently it's not even just off by a
little bit right all right where you're
like oh wow we won World War two no
Russia did yeah we didn't beat the Nazis
Russia did yeah they lost like eight
million people yeah in that war yeah I
mean it was in their yard sure then
there was no nobody got shot in America
you know in wind gap buildings in cities
completely destroyed like sixty percent
of Russia was destroyed yeah they lost
millions imagine if like it rained bomb
just so cute I people then is known to
was up so they've also killed way more
people oh yeah tons and tons and tons
and tons I mean it's like if if it rip
five hours a day for four months rained
bombs in Los Angeles yeah yeah what
would be left after those months and
rubble yeah you look at it like tons of
Europe was just flattened yeah look flat
and gone yeah basically know what would
have happened um without the Russian
front well that but I mean even like
what Europe would look like now had
there not been a World War two mmm it'd
be way more crowded yeah yeah a lot more
Jews it would look like fall I would
look like I winter lane will died I mean
that's what Switzerland's like switching
winds so beautiful and cuz everything is
so beautiful and old yeah like every
single building is 500 you way more
people older build a every ever it looks
like this ID lick chocolate factory from
every little city like this is the most
beautiful like wisp another like it is
called Bronx to small places like yeah
yeah every place let me make watches
here at chocolate bar yeah literally
every place is like beautiful winding
cobblestone streets cuz no one bombed
the living [ __ ] out of it yeah you know
like why is everybody here so nice it's
cuz well we don't have anything that you
guys want to steal yeah we've said I
have no I have really not there when i
was in skated even remember they i was
at because they don't have like they
don't make their own TV really it was
maybe not every country but it would
might have been norway or one of those
countries and they were like oh we they
don't they only just buy TV from other
countries because they consider it
really stupid to spend the country's
money on making television on any level
so they just buy like british TV and
french TV they don't make like there's
no like nor weed there's no like swiss
TV stars really because they're just
like if they're going to spend money on
like public broadcasting it sound like
classical music or like culture like
things that consider like value
culture as opposed to just like sitcoms
and [ __ ] like that just vacationing
there were you know I toured with
Whitney oh cool how are the shows
they're there I didn't talk about
Whitney Houston yes it was her final
tour well yeah um it would the shows are
fun it's just there's a delay because
they all speak English but it takes them
like just a minute yeah and you can't
make any reference it's the only place
it's sort of stunk was Belgium like day
and afterwards guy was like a Belgium
they don't laugh they just applaud I was
like that's not stand up that's weird
yeah they would have just you would do
like and I was like giving a speech kind
of an in the end you get this huge
applause like their end of the bit or
though the end of the show how do you
yeah well and then afterwards they were
like you're so funny you're like what
are you sure are you sure you didn't
make noises very clever your Amsterdam
was obviously super fun yeah and a great
city period how do like but the thing is
with like with laughter is like how do
you prevent but the key to a good joke
is the surprise so like that the
surprise makes you laugh so how do they
watch it and not have that involuntary
like desire to laugh and then at the end
go like that was really funny what may
be the language barrier keeps it from
from triggering that surprised because
like the the rhythm is probably totally
different than what they find funny they
just kind of get and the verbiage is
just like almost in the wrong order so
there they have to like decipher it it's
like if you spoke enough Spanish to get
like beat to know all the words of a
joke yeah you wouldn't laugh at it
because you'd be like that means the
garage [ __ ] is your you're flipping the
the rhythm or yeah exactly maybe maybe
that's a yeah they're translating it I
think too much to at least there other
places they laughed sounds like these
cities need to be bummed but everyone in
everyone was [ __ ] beautiful or the
ugliest thing you've ever seen there's
no like middle ground now because they
ought cuz they see they all yeah they
all they won't intermix like
Scandinavians are obsessed with keeping
their blood aryan they don't talk about
in that way but like the only guy news
like
I live there for five years he's like
they'll have sex with non-swiss people
but they would never like have children
with them but they were like pure Swiss
blood so they're getting like their
birth rate went like are going down
because they like kind of their kind of
inbred so they're either these tall
Adonis people or they're like golems
like these like coke bottle glasses like
albino weirdos right that look like
Harry Potter people there either
gorgeous so they look like us yes oh I
looked like I will I like I people
looked at me especially that women who
were all taller than me like they looked
at me like I was clearly diseased were
you single when you were there yeah I
don't remember yeah I think so did you
hook up with anybody know oh I remember
if i was single or not i think i was
yeah I don't REM breather yeah but uh
yeah way he looked looking so they
looked at me like I had a dev or
something like pretty wrong with me like
oh look what are you sick yeah why are
you so small I don't like I'm free on
period blood it's me it's gonna be so
much more international comedy now so
many more comedians are going overseas
is like more of a market for it Netflix
has all these specials now from other
countries yeah yeah we shot this guy
yeah like shot in German and subtitled
in English yeah it's weird because you
for years like stand-up was an American
thing and then they had it in other
english-speaking countries it was like a
part of the culture but when it just
started blowing like everybody all the
sudden was like doing gigs in Australia
everyone but Australia Australian
England have had it I've had stand up
like it's huge in Canada right now stand
up is ya que horas is out yeah a lot of
english-speaking places I get it up bike
more Canadians and probably Americans
only social media by the Queen for years
though we've heard of like oh so Eddie
Izzard from from Canada certain
comedians and stuff from yeah australia
in canada uh Peters birla England is
what I meant uh yeah Russell from from
Canada but never in my life I've been
like oh yeah that famous comic from
Germany or Mexico or Columbia right Alex
gone through netflix and there's like
so-and-so live I'm like who's that guy
and it's some dude from Mexico who is
like this big following yeah does the
whole thing in Spanish and there was
another guy in in German I tried to
watch the german one I would like to
watch it because I'm it's on netflix
it's called like pure duhr yeah in
Germany or in Berlin or no ignore or
something in Berlin and I was like [ __ ]
it you know and I started and it was
like he goes up in the audience kind of
lightly applause is like this little
like hall you know and he goes up there
and it's very casual and he's kind of
just like it looks like he's just
talking there's no like didn't feel like
it had like this rhythm that was you
know or an act whatever and I'm just
reading the subtitles and he was sort of
getting laughs at what it just didn't
feel in any way shape or form like
American stand-up mmm like you're up
there you're like now you're reading
sometimes I will contextually or his
jokes like fun did you find them funny
were written really like jokes and I was
like maybe he's just like riffing or
[ __ ] around what she was kind of
little bit he kept talking about how
Americans were gonna see you this and
making jokes about that that we're kind
of getting laughs I was like it's gotta
be part of the thing because you know
how many subscribers are in America yeah
watching this and I was like okay so I
gave it another like maybe 10 minutes
and then I was just like I don't know
that I'm gonna get into this and I can
just watch it later that was like a week
or two ago but I feel like it's similar
to Belgians watching you go like okay
yeah we see what you're doing there is a
British comic that came in did are shown
santa monica and she was talking as she
goes in in England she's like british
comedian street doing like an hour much
more like a one-person show because a
lot of its built around you know that
you go to Edinburgh in Utah in its it's
not just like here's like 20 bits it's
like a one-act players yeah as they
treated like a one-act play so I think
sometimes that may be like it the lid
the way you talk is just much more
casual because you're telling us to a
long you it's functioning like a story
we're like a long jokes but it's not
like because American stand-up is like
there's like a unspoken every 15 seconds
20 30 second like joke joke joke joke
joke you know so like British
stand up like it has more way more of a
conversational feel you know more
stories and we have happening more
American stand-up now the last ten years
but for a long time it's been like that
there and this this German think sort of
felt that way but like the language
barrier was like I I'm gonna read the
subtitles but they don't they're not
written as like one liners are set up
punch I don't think this is gonna happen
for me but I want to try and watch more
of it to see like it is there that big
of a language barrier you know that's
why would one see that one just because
I you know I took German I spoke to him
for a while you should totally watch
yeah that's why when you said you're
like oh I'd like to see that one just
because in that same sense for you like
I would be a little bit behind with it
but yeah I think halfway through I think
my German would get better don't a lot
of German speak English a lot of almost
all so I would imagine if you watch it
and got a handle of it you could
probably figure like oh if I could get
to Germany to do shows you forget so
it's just a little different like I'd
have to talk like this kind of right
have to they just you know feel it feels
differently yeah maybe yeah I'm gonna
watch the mexico city one whatever the
guy's name is recorded in mexico city
but i guess he's like a big deal i heard
that Reggie Watts new one was really
funny I haven't seen that one yet but
the Michael che specials really good I
saw that I ever seen it i saw was out
yeah I like that one it was shot
differently earth calling Quinn's is
really good too is that the one about
history yeah those are the two out that
have been mentioned immediately that one
I heard was good obviously mulaney's
newest one is great that's probably
whenever someone asked me what comedy on
netflix what specials I'm like mulaney's
first but now that Michael che one I
think is is really good that just came
out Reggie watch your sayings good I'm
gonna liven Cena my sister saw and she
was done i'm probably gonna watch that
tonight but she said it's really almost
like i you were saying more and that's
how he is anyway with all his music and
all adds more one-man show ish but she
said there's a bunch of like fake sitcom
right you know commercials and you know
it's all kinds that's cool it's not just
i came on strong like that boxing and
[ __ ] it's like all kinds of cuts to
their different that's good which i
think that's the way a lot of that's
going to go like the production value of
a lot of these specials are going to be
almost like a one-hour kind of
sketch show kind of thing and yeah it's
like a comedy special it can be all
kinds of comedy that have to do that's
in the 80 thing always did that like
there was always a sketch at the
beginning yeah knowing his ones in the
middle yep that cuts to other varieties
that's what was cool about perrette ease
was those weird cutaways yeah yeah dog
in the audience I like never like that
sure people like sleeping yeah yeah not
interested there something I mean
there's just so many specials now you
have to do they have to change in some
way do you gotta now be special again
yeah I loved uh I don't know if it was
last one or two specials ago but Dave
cross where he was like across the
street eating in a restaurant in the
very beginning and like hey we need a
guy like hey what do you do he's like my
guess so and it just walks into files
and right across the street right
through the back door right on the stage
and then he starts talking yeah I
thought that you know little things like
that i always think make those specials
a little more special when is your album
coming out ah first week of the new
years so right on the fifth or sixth of
the january okay perfect that's which I
was working on it last night yeah yeah
yeah that's how figured you know late
Christmas present or super early
Christmas I was working on the last
night I finally am now like like I heard
the first like 15 minutes with
compression and everything okay and so
it's kind of like and it's weird like to
edit it because you know I have these
different channels of it where it's like
my mic and then the audience's mike
separately left side right side yeah so
i'm going through just making notes just
like i'm just talking into a mic like in
a room it sounds like yeah like you can
barely hear the audience unless a joke
really kills it's so faint right because
it's just this mic in my ear yeah yeah
so it's i'm like i think i remember that
joke doing better than this you know
it's like and then once i do i heard it
last night with like full audience and
I'm like oh there they are yeah thank
God because after going through it so
many times without really hearing the
audience on it which is so weird it is
weird you start to kind of go like I
hope this sounds good some comedy clubs
have that uh for some weird reason some
of the improv have this where they have
speakers in the bathroom
him and so you can still hear the show
but it's just the mic yes so you're
hearing the guy talk but like you're not
hearing the laughter that you just were
hearing when you're in the showroom and
and I get partly why like a conceited so
follow with the comic st. but like why
not also have the [ __ ] crowd laughing
because it sounds so weird yet does like
the guy like pauses uh-huh you know and
then nothing happens they're like what
the irvine one does that matter
something's clearly missing at the
[ __ ] audience that i right it's so
weird but yeah when you do hear yourself
and you're like wait if first you're
like wait this really wonder what
happened ooh and then you're like [ __ ]
to the recording [ __ ] up and your
mindset smiling and they go oh no we
have the left and right audience mics
and you're like ah it's there I lit the
first who knows when it was a long time
ago but first time I realized that they
had that when I was performing there and
I won't say who but there was a comic
that you knows a bunch it was like one
of those like comedy juice or whatever
the head one of those like six or a
pretty funny women might have been
pretty funny women is on and I'm I've
never been on a pretty funny woman yes
you are yeah they have like their one
dude and I going exactly you yeah it's
like pretty funny it's all women and a
half there like guy there was a like a
guy coming up or something maybe they
don't need my honor but I think they
used to I did he [ __ ] what's it bust our
balls so I went in the butt to the
bathroom and I said to myself god
[ __ ] hate this guy and when I start
pissing then I was like I only hear his
voice and I'm like I just following get
away from this idiot that's really funny
so you recorded it November fourth
November fourth I recorded it in in
Indiana which is right outside Chicago
right by Lake Michigan which is where I
grew up yeah I'm so cool like all my
friends from Chicago they're all my
college friends with anybody still lived
around so you know the second show which
was a super PAC the first show was
crowded and great but the second show
was like super duper packed I probably
knew 40 people first and last name nice
of the once and hear what I was amazing
you know I like that so like a weird
things and editing it like I have to
draw pull it back because I would make
some sort of reference where a bunch of
people would cheer yeah because they
personally know this and I'm
sure I gotta bring that down cuz
otherwise you're gonna listen to a go
what did I just miss right there yeah
like if you don't know they're like
googling the name of a street you're
like I why is this funny yeah I tell a
story in there about a little person
that I went to high school with who the
one day I went out for wrestling because
I was so skinny he was on the wrestling
team and because I'm so skinny my weight
class was closest to his so I didn't
even want to be there in the first place
but now I'm like how great now I got to
fight a [ __ ] and I want to be here you
know yes I gotta tell that whole story
and I mentioned his name in it in in the
beginning which I'll pull that out just
so I don't get sued half sued a little
this yeah I get a little fiery little
Sue's me so I always had the intention
of you know I'll pull his name out of
there but the minute i mention his name
like 40 people cheer and unlike people
gonna talk google like who is this guy
price of fame sell little things like
that yeah that's gotta go yeah and it in
it really have really learned a lot
about um the process of editing it's
really maddening yeah I don't have the
patience for it yeah I always wonder
like how the [ __ ] people can sit in a
room for hours and hours hours editing
like audio too seems what is way easier
than video like imagine editing a
[ __ ] film or deviation in a special
same thing over and over i would lose i
would just go well it's over now and
then bash my head into a screen and
you're so close to when you're when it's
something personal yours like in and got
you know great point because i can't
even imagine cutting a film that was my
passion project or something but even
just this like i could spend 10 hours on
five minutes of this right and go like
oh let me hear with like that a little
louder a little okay bring that up when
you know yeah that's what you gotta have
somebody else do it right otherwise like
i'll be like however you done yeah it's
like I'm just got like I was doing a dr
and I and I the guy like match thing and
I was like I was like it seems really
hard to mush all this stuff together the
guy just look at me like a man [ __ ]
goddamn it yeah thank you just like yeah
really really is but I think editors get
paid pretty damn way yeah because it is
and these were just like sound editors
and that usually I'm really good at a dr
but i just couldn't
I like I couldn't make it sound same and
I mean we had to do it 50 times and
usually I can knock it out of good at
mimicking myself and I just there was
like a way it sounded like an air like
the amount of air some [ __ ] and the guy
was like can we keep going they let you
listen to know I was here the whole time
and it just he was like it sounds there
it it was a little more air behind it or
be like seems like it was a little less
clencher like more knows it was in it
and we just had it took an hour which is
[ __ ] torture yessir just go nuts yeah
but yeah they the guy was just like no I
have to cuz otherwise it sticks out like
I can still spot it when i watch movies
and stuff you can tell the line all the
time yeah whenever I watched and it's
always like you're like oh yeah they had
to go to a pick up on that like it yeah
even it just doesn't it's so hard to get
it to match when they're outside yep
when when two actors are outside in the
rain it's like that's not their voice
when they're running in a battlefield
like that's all [ __ ] you gotta redo and
that's why it's good to have those like
separate audio audience mics outside of
the in line right because you can really
play around with like if you're mixing
different shows even or something like
that like you can get it and it's just
audio you can get it to where like no
one notices but like if it's your thing
you will sit there mm-hmm and like
tinker with it for hours and hours and
hours and I just like I I couldn't I
couldn't sit there and do that like I
gave it to my engineer and I was like do
this here's how I want it to sound send
me what you have and he goes here's like
two different versions and whatever i
think i toid this the other day yeah
yeah and he sent and i was like oh yeah
that's really good i'm like and what
about this and that and then and then we
went in like listen to it in his studio
and went back and forth and he's really
good at what he does so I was just like
how the [ __ ] do you he's just like oh
it's just there's all these different
programs and things like that and I kind
of like enjoy doing it but I'm like how
do you do this for something that isn't
yours yeah like I could sit there and I
wanted to like hear it because I want it
to come out Yeah right cuz it's my thing
yeah but like to take on someone else's
stand-up album or like or music or a
movie or whatever and spend hours and
hours and hours and use like you just
must [ __ ] love editing especially
that musical like music or anything if
your editor and you know you're getting
paid that's your job but like if you
just like let's say you just despise
death metal you know and you spend three
months working on some album for some
band you just these guys are horrible
right well you're like you know [ __ ]
gotta eat yeah you know ya gonna pay the
rest my landlord doesn't care that I
hate death metal right you know you got
yeah I don't I just don't I don't have
the patience to like I could not be an
editor without losing my marbles I know
I mean I couldn't couldn't do it you
know that's why it all works so good
with this Opie it's like maybe they find
it sad it really satisfying to fix
things where they see a joke to like I
can fix that they're like I know how do
I know how to make that part really
[ __ ] work like I'm gonna go to here
and then I'm gonna come a shoot to this
angle you know like yeah like from like
a video like no I'm gonna go right to
the close-up night like I think that
probably is pretty satisfying I guess
yeah there's people that it's really
active you can there's a lot of moving
parts so maybe if you like that if it's
not like boring necessarily yeah I guess
that's that level of like repetition and
stuff just like for me I would just like
get me away from it like a dress and the
other thing that where it would may it
would seem maddening is that becomes how
you then see the world all the time yeah
meeting at week yeah my friend is like
that will be watching some things like
I'd be like that edit like he were my
friend who works in TV like so when
we're watch watching something ye all
will always do that yo prayers just like
I saw that edit I'm like where like I
[ __ ] notice yeah as a bad I'm like
what are you seeing and can you keep it
to yourself watching like uh well I
realize I'm like oh that person blew
their coverage is why would they be why
would they stay on that close-up on the
other person's talking like oh they
don't have a good take of that side yeah
that means someone [ __ ] blue they're
like good side yeah and if you like you
know we work in this industry where I
will notice a lot of things just you
know because I've shot a lot of stuff
and you know Ben things you'll notice I
was watching
it's always sunny yeah I which had a lot
that shows never not funny to me and
there was some seen one of the episodes
they want to give Danny DeVito's
character he needs an intervention ok em
he's just drinking stupid things box
wine all the time and there's one he's
walking up to this house and he's
chugging this beer and he Chuck's it in
the street and it says this has says his
line or whatever and then as they go but
if you look in the background we chucked
in the street there's already a beer can
in the middle of the street like this is
the second take yeah it made it yeah
which I'm like all a month that must
have been they must have heard this must
be the second take of this yeah that's
my girlfriend I quite a mic cuz look as
if she's like all good catch ya or
they're like you can throw distraught to
Dave thrown at the sound guy yeah and
we'll have it out there uh-huh we like
the end of Reservoir Dogs he doesn't
shoot enough people oh yeah yeah I'll
re-watch it and cuz i looked it up he
doesn't shoot everyone but everyone
falls down he all there's like I think
for people that all fall down but he
only shoots three people and then I
looked it up in Quentin Tarantino's like
we didn't have enough money to go back a
bit oh really yeah Wow don't tell that's
Oliver Stone it was like one of those
you know think seems like yeah we we
didn't have enough money that's it I saw
some De Niro moving I remember I brought
it up to this commercial director who
was incredibly mean he goes because when
he jumped out of the plane why didn't
they show him I go I don't go see
another [ __ ] money to shoot in a
plane like are they then the money for
the camera they show him in the plane
jump out he's like and he's like I hate
that [ __ ] i watch like oh they didn't
know the money for the [ __ ] rigged
yes you do not look at stuff that way
after yeah you've been a director and
editor an actor writer this got your
noticing when I watch bat when I watched
the second Lord of the Rings and in the
bat there's that 25 minute battle scene
or whatever I was like this is four
months in the rain at night [ __ ] this
movie like [ __ ] being in this movie man
yeah you have this job [ __ ] you aren't
doing that [ __ ] no thanks bro heartbeat
so you're ridiculous no residual no
residuals and Lord of the Rings really
yeah
weird yeah which by the way those would
have been substantial I'll bet digital's
oh absolutely i remember i saw i would
see one of the hobbits and during pilot
season going out for the same parts as
me and we'd all every other actor would
be like what in the [ __ ] are you doing
here man you have an action figure Rep
like no that was the deal no residuals
that's weird I mean cuz you're talking
about even low end a million bucks for
each of the main characters probably
just residuals just residual yeah yeah
yeah cuz I always heard those stories
everyone knew like a guy who had two
lines in Titanic my ex-wife knew a guy
who was friends with one of the like uh
band members in Titanic the violin guy
so one day he went to the mailbox
there's a check for a hundred and ten
grand yeah on a Wednesday this before
the SAG residual trackers usually do
today let's check the water bill whole
[ __ ] like [ __ ] life change on a like
oh gosh humanik win the lottery every
like two months yeah ah and you still
eat people ate those the titanic
residual stories are plenty because
there was a so many people in the movie
and all they needed all of them the
whole time so everyone made [ __ ]
mountains of money yeah it's like you're
on the boat it's not like they're
cutting away to a bunch of different
locations yeah like everybody's there
like Billy Zane's fine I heard the guy
that played the iceberg made a killing
yeah I read a thing today that said that
it's funny you mentioned that that that
the iceberg that sank the Titanic they
believe formed started forming during
the King Tut era Wow nerds I love
hearing so added to ya super facts uber
faxes on uber fact I wonder if it's true
I mean they usually this stuff usually
seems relatively accurate and you know
you factor how old that is the size of
it yeah yeah funny to sit there know
that someone sat down and tried to
figure that out right oh no all that
iceberg is and then like a week later I
found it I mean you can watch a guy like
you know I mean really blown up netflix
on this thing by the way this my podcast
t even is to dip [ __ ] buddy brought to
you by netflix you watch any of those
like science document is in all this and
you you know you
watching you go all these people so
smart one of the one of my favorite
quotes from the Civil War is there's a
historian named shelby foote he talks
about there was like a senator who said
like oh this war will be over in a week
you'll be able to clean up all the blood
with a handkerchief and he goes I think
you could probably get a doctorate
calculating how many handkerchiefs that
would have taken to mop up all the blood
of the Civil War I think it would have
taken like a trillion yeah that's fine
yeah I think one of the ones I would
they were talking about that ice and so
much as documentary and they would what
they would do is to check air quality to
back track of like Oh house air quality
now compared they would just drill
straight down and get like almost like a
the size of a baseball bat in you know
diameter or whatever but it would be
like drilling all the way down like you
know forever know in this ice because it
never goes away so big and because it's
frozen they would just slice like
quarter thin things and can go all the
way back and check the air quality 300
years ago yeah you know just by studying
that little sliver from win that ice
form 300 years ago right and you're like
I never would have thought about that i
would just used it as a sword or
something is bad i got like a lifesaver
ice lifesaver look it's my guys %
isolate Avery I got huge I stick yeah
that's what I do is that we need it I
would just be like Arctic lemonade look
at my giant ass yeah q we could make the
coldest lemonade ever yeah I like you
know we can let's just watch it melt the
Sun yeah exactly I wish there was on cod
and seals with it man you know what I
would love I wish it was a podcast
called like mean scientists where they
were just like you guys are so [ __ ]
stupid like they just taught these asked
like normal people questions like why
don't you know anything right why are
you people know anything what's so
interesting is like you look at all
these older scientific discoveries
especially people that have found
galaxies and universes and come up with
theories of the expansion of the
universe
rom and all and the speed of it
expanding all this and they all get
debunked writers are just some regular
Joe Blow that does it and then two years
later it's almost always the people that
debunk it that then yeah prove it to be
true and then get credit for it yeah
there's like I was a hero where I was
watching and reading it but it was a
scientist sitting there talking about
how you can't have an ego in science
where because you have to sit here and
come up with these theories about the
universe and all these different things
and all they are theories until they're
proven wrong and then you know a newer
better one that was built off the one
you came up with who appears and then
that one gets to stroke as it's been
happening for hundreds and thousands of
years oh yeah people I killed for saying
the earth wasn't for ya Earth's totally
flat and then that gets debunked and
then now you know that it's like only a
sort of flat yeah I'm pretty flat yeah
and uh but I was like oh yeah I guess
you can't because it's not about you
it's just about like getting the fact
yeah so if you sit there and think like
these are the facts you gotta go like
this makes perfect sense up until right
now given all the information that we
have until someone takes all that and
then like adds new information and you
have to think of yourself as part of the
process of like discovery forever but I
was like that's gotta be I guess
frustrating in a way but because you can
never like I guess you're never right
you know right you just sit here and go
like this makes the most sense of
everything with what information we have
right now but I'm probably wrong you
know yeah yeah I belong I loved uh that
uh arrival oh yeah oh what a beautiful
move that movie have you seen it arrival
it's really good so good it's about um I
won't give any and much away but it's
like alien ships come to earth like 12
of them I believe these big like giant
like eggs and there's a floating in
random parts of the earth and different
countries uh try and communicate with
them to figure out why they're here then
it goes on from there but it is unlike
any other ailee there's no like into
pendants day style battle stuff it's
really able to use the alien story as a
device to tell a different story yeah
Amy out Amy Adams I'm net force would
occur an awesome generator Jeremy Renner
great cast acting's amazing the stories
really good it's about like it's about
humanity in connection and all that sort
of stuff in language and things it's not
about like you know aliens is not an
action film but it's so good i only
knock is that one of those aliens didn't
[ __ ] somebody you see the aliens oh yeah
they got X or no they got a lot of stuff
yeah they look like they might have a
dick ok hi a couple I saw that yeah they
definitely look like they saw that movie
the founder with a it's about the guy
who founded McDonnell's oh yeah how's
that oh it i really liked it yeah it's
really good he reminds he reminded
documentaries it's a movie okay it
Michael Keaton please ray kroc that's
right it reminds you of reminded me of
Steve Jobs kinda ok but it's worth
seeing for sure get a screen or some
yeah yeah mom one time my group you know
when you get older and as you get into
these like crazy conspiracy your
everyone's trying to [ __ ] you out of
something when you get old yeah you know
if at the core you know smallest level
get you kids get out of my yard all the
way up to you know they did something
their world was round my grandmother's
husband and maybe I've told you guys
this performing I said in his pockets
but he was convinced boycott McDonald's
because they are screwing us all of
their burgers are kangaroo meat right
you're like yeah the inexpensive
kangaroo meat the shipping alone exactly
yeah enough kangaroos where the kangaroo
farms where they're making all the video
not be able to see that many kangaroos
from space I'm trying to eat a regular
cow burger but deed nothing they're
sending us these dodo egg omelets
didn't you look at me up yeah you're a
mean there for sure [ __ ] us but not
on kangaroo meat it's quite the opposite
if it's anything spy just like a bunch
of chewed-up socks or something did you
see the due to punch the kangaroo in the
face of a dog I probably watch that clip
fifties ya know that was a great one
indicators like ready to go oh [ __ ] is
all yeah I mean they're supposedly
[ __ ] yeah yeah it's awesome but he
punched me didn't even do faze him yeah
so crazy you wonder that's the first
time he's been punched by a human which
is like oh you guys do that to look like
it wasn't he took like [ __ ] yeah he had
a chin on him it was Nate Diaz of
kangaroos by the way he was there last
night I saw I'm so mad that I'm him in
his brother to Nick yeah yeah who's
actually better than Nate it looks like
the real badass I mean it's all there at
eight and I was like hanging that yeah I
was in the home at eight he's okay you
come in the Congress or Christmas pretty
much how did you know about this and I
know it's funny you've been out of Los
Angeles for three months you've been
back for one day and you're right to the
console are they yeah hang out the Diaz
brothers right uh so we go way
sidetracked so the album uh you're
almost done editing you're adding like a
bet when you're best friends yet which
is what he does which is great uh and
what's it gonna be called return to the
red state okay and it was four days I
recorded it in Indiana where Pence's
from uh and four days before the
election so it's a little bit of it is
you know to historically a red state
always yeah yeah I the Ku Klux Klan
started oh cool they go to the show uh
there's a few of them to you bro you
have more than over to shows you had
more than 200 people there was some clan
oh by the way what what's the name of
that real birth of a nation you know
that old all DW Griffith yep our hardest
action movie first Western a lot of that
is in the UH Oliver Stone thing you know
that you know the Ku Klux Klan didnêt
they never burned crosses yeah it was
that was in that movie because it looked
cool yeah I from then on I just learned
that in that documentary the 13th I
gotta watch that that that that is I saw
that that's number one lead impressing
though it's very defined watch it yeah
because I've been watching like real
heavy movies lately and that's ahead I
gotta take a [ __ ] break the 13th is
very heavy and you're like it made me
feel hopeless it right it it makes you
feel like there's nothing I can do
America just decided to torture this
group of people and systemically has
kept doing it forever and you just see
the hopelessness in them a lot of times
like they just risen for life for
loitering ya Yin Yin like well we can't
laven let's just take your like oh
that's the way you take like oh we will
don't want to vote we'll just make them
felons okay just make them all felons so
give away anymore yeah of history and
then they all die in the end right so
it's like spoiler yeah the 13th is rough
yeah I gotta watch them but then watch
the there's a new king of kong style
documentary called man vs. snake okay oh
you know what you guys have to [ __ ]
see but I can I say whenever he makes
that face and there's that long pause oh
by the way you were totally gonna look
whenever Nick gives me one of those you
know buckle your seatbelt here comes
something good they have it your way get
ready can have you my pot it's gonna be
the best yeah the bad yeah UNT on easy
there for a while the word it's the best
um it's a documentary right guys I'm out
of here good job and join my podcast now
is it it's a documentary called tickled
oh I saw it you saw it yeah we went well
amazing it is it what is writable we
can't actually talk about being a
credible way that why it's incredible is
because every five minutes you like wait
what's happening now what is I mean okay
this is the whole thing I leave you all
give you the setup there's a journalist
who finds out on YouTube he's based in
New Zealand and he's kind of built a
career on like I news about kind of
weird stuff a wet days on YouTube and he
sees this video about competitive
tickling and he goes this is weird
interesting content is a documentary or
awesome elementary
doc competitive tickling so then he
contacts the people and he goes hey I
would like to do a story on it they
respond almost right away with like they
face found out that he's like a
homosexual journalist or whatever and
like made that the focal point of thing
we don't want to have contact with any
homosexuals ababa blonde have them talk
about her thing and he was just like
well that was weird and then they kept
sending emails about how his lifestyle
was like inappropriate and anyone and
then they called him a [ __ ] and after
that he was like okay now minute now I'm
gonna start investigating and I'm gonna
do a story yes and then he proceeds to
uncover the craziest [ __ ] what is this
on because I'm so in you have to get it
on like itunes or and yeah i bought it
it's like 12 but I get on my fire stick
I don't know I games on prime or
whatever the hell it is I yeah you can
buy it on Amazon okay out there it is a
well thought okay but or I mean maybe
you can if you want illegally download
or whatever but I don't know it's there
but I it came so highly recommended yeah
and a banger and like the way you're
like what could be underneath what's the
dark underbelly a competitive i could
i'm like i have to watch it so i was
told about this yesterday watched it
last night I was like I can't believe
what I'm a hundred percent watching so
good did and that I won't tell you
anything about it but what happens in
the end though I will time I get
everyone out more about it but i will
say almost all this big screenings
they've had of it the main subject keeps
showing up and yelling at the filmmakers
and arguing with them oh my god i didn't
know you didn't look that up he showed
up he showed up to the sundance
screening and was like that's [ __ ]
okay don't give away any more don't go
away anywhere video of it ok idea but
also but don't look up anything about
this week again watch it and let
yourself just like let it all just
unfold in front of you just be like I
can't even believe this is yeah it goes
to a place that I've never seen a doctor
Mary go to where you're like this is the
weirdest most specific [ __ ] ever it's it
really [ __ ] did it'll make you sit
there and go people are so bizarre like
they are just up to the
weirdest craziest most inexplicable [ __ ]
just watchin watch have you seen on
netflix it's on netflix called tabloid
no it's about it's about a woman and it
took this happened in the 70s who kind
of fell in love with a guy and then he
was a mormon and so he goes on his
mission and then she sort of kidnaps and
try to get him back in England whoa and
it's super [ __ ] weird and we're
watching and weird Wow but it's it's on
it's on netflix and it's right now it's
free it's a derelict old tabloid and
tickled and man vs. snake man vs. think
is like king of kong it's about a guy
trying to break a video game record oh i
did see that i loved it i didn't see
that I saw that I'm gonna watch I saw
that one and yeah and then he gets it it
as Reyes and then the great thing about
it is the weird that one long haired
dude from king of kong the the hot sauce
salesman is also in man vs. tick yeah
yeah cuz they still you know it's still
governed by that one plate that one and
is it in the arcade no I built it is
somewhere around there but it's not
Indiana but it's maybe Michigan
Pennsylvania sore no it's close to me
it's more in them in the Midwest yeah
maybe even Illinois or somewhere similar
yeah but it's governed by that video
game guy who determines all the high
scores who always wears a referee shirt
like a by the time the best yeah you
could see that guy that guy looks like
he beats off to weird things I mean
what's not weird to be off him mm-hmm
there's no such thing as normal noting
to my therapist yeah that's so I'm
excited for it to come out it was great
you know what was where I got lucky in
you know we talked about this affair
which is is it's almost weird nowadays
to have affair conversations with people
there's like what else I'm having a good
conversation some of yours whenever I'm
having a good good conversation with
sonam like what a shame no one else is
enjoying this organic moment yeah let's
rehab this conversation on a podcast
word for word but the Cubs went to seven
games and the day that I and I got this
ticket months in advance to fly back to
record my album yeah the day before two
days before I was good flying to well
two days before I was going to do my
album was game 7 and I was flying in
Chicago like an hour
for the game so I literally got to like
be in Chicago while the Cubs won the
World Series and like be a part of that
craziness yeah a dude it was just I've
never seen anything like it it really
was one of the best weeks of my life
because got to be a part of that got to
see also many people haven't seen in so
long fans were really cool people drove
from Iowa these kids are of eight hours
to come to my album taping got so bombed
they tweeted at me the next day I was
like dude you guys do not drive I think
you have an eight hour drive yeah
granted most of its through corn but you
are going to die and then they tweeted
me a next day man we all slept in the
parking lot in our car we need to 9am
I'm like well done fellas that's cool
did well Rama to punk rock we're gonna
like see their favorite punk band you
dry weather like there's so many people
that such a great wedding like dudes are
not coming any closer we gotta go to
[ __ ] Chicago to see face to face
what's to it or driving yeah it was so
cool there's so many people I can punch
drunk shirts or so many people in T band
is to dip [ __ ] buddy shirt by the way
guys didn't know we had merged but it is
your the Sharpie she visited a as a duct
tape like a witch whose chirps used to
be that the black keys oh it definitely
yeah yeah yeah they still have that and
then they actually printed it yeah which
is better yeah they have smart merch and
design mm-hmm it's all one of the guys
brothers I think it's a driver's brother
I really does all the design he's
designed other album covers like he's
legit no what's your album cover gonna
look like uh it is uh like an animated
state of Indiana it's red and is like a
kind of an animated version of me and it
looks like the state of Indiana armor to
make sure that i did I was gonna be the
cover oh yeah that's yeah they're dope
that was the poster for the show and the
cover and and it's slightly different
the wordage will be not for the date and
location it'll just be the name of the
album and all that sort of stuff what's
funny about all my dip [ __ ] [ __ ] your
watch shameless all my friends are like
the Gallagher's at me that I grew up
with in Chicago so I'm signing all these
posters that they had made for all these
fans after show
after show too yeah and after show tues
where all my friends were there and
their wives and all that stuff right but
you know things don't change too much
because like towards yen one of the
promoters of the shows like hey did you
take a bunch of the posters i go i got
like four or five like i like one for my
girlfriend went from my friend one for
my mom and for other mom I got like four
or five they go no no this like a lot
missing I'm like oh no I didn't maybe
somebody jacked him whatever and then we
all after the show one of my friends
lives not too far away from there so a
bunch of us crashed at his house yeah
and he's oh by the way dude look what in
here like 40 pulses I'm like what do you
stole the wallpapering your Dan why do
you mean we don't even need those like I
would have given you one why do you have
so many and he basically stole them from
you is it do you know where would I like
you took that from me I tell you I got
him so I could have them like it like
that is I took all the ones I needed I
totally get it I totally get it yeah
absolutely understand that mentality
100% like in our 40s we're still lacking
like we were just got it that's the same
guys that we used to like go to we used
to play so competitively John Madden
football Sega Genesis that we got
creative about how we would front be
frustrated in brake controllers like one
time I like calmly like I you know they
like a last-minute field goal beats me
mm-hmm interesting and I just stand up
open a drawer pull out a hammer and I
sense and pieces are just going
everywhere twirl them and launching them
off the balcony but then we had to start
going to parties to steal other place
they uh Sega Genesis controllers there's
a great video online right now have a
Japanese dad destroying his son I saw it
with a sledgehammer yeah her beautiful
and that kid what an ass about it was
the best though at the end him crying as
he falls down and cries and then when he
falls back like his clothing line it's
like after all that I love a good
hilarious viral video my favorite thing
is the dad dad at the sweatshirt he has
on with the bear like an adorable panda
on it yeah was Karan like I'm gonna [ __ ]
yeah this any took a shot at that he got
the TV too he was I can go wrong when he
walked in with just like he just had
like no expression yeah and you're like
sums about to go down there's gotta be
nothing more frustrating than an
ungrateful kid of yours oh yeah you're a
Japanese businessman is like in a diet
is desk you come home and your [ __ ]
kid all this is play video games and not
talk to you you're like this watch this
shaved blonde hair and his [ __ ]
skater but you know you're just like get
a job [ __ ] for real I worked so hard
for you and you can't even get off your
ass oh by the way I did that virtual
reality thing that tell you this I did
this virtual let's first time I've done
it but like one of the higher end like
cooler ones where it's like tethered to
like a really high powered computer
unbelievable yeah unbelievable yeah I'm
like afraid of that tech I watched one
it was pretty crazy I put that thing on
is you watch the video pretty what the I
put the head they had the virtual
reality walk through the thing and this
is the one that you would love because
it was that Google one where you can
like draw and change your brushes and on
and whenever you draw after we're done
with the pot I'll show you a little
video of it the eye cuz I after I did I
went and found their like promotional
video for it and a there's so many
different like because you have to kind
of almost like joysticks in your hand
and one is like all the different realms
and brushes and pallets and stuff you
can use yeah and the other one you can
like trigger and point to those and
change all your things and move around
and stuff and you know you can like for
like snow and you can just hold the
trigger and just go like this and it's
just starts snowing on you yeah well are
these Amber's and you can do it nail to
start rising up and like I was like in
like outer space like them they're like
oh now look to your left you look to the
left like the moon's right there it's
like the size of a beach ball like you
can lay under it and look at me and
everything you've drawn make stays there
like in three dimension yeah so it's
technically not get so good it like
worries what they said that they're
doing I was over at off what is it
called josh isn't that's where I did it
when I was over there and then what
they're talking about is not that far
away it's actually kind of happening now
but it's going to get bigger is doing
stand-up shows so all the comics will
have that and then
you look and they're like when you do it
you're looking at like a real audience
of people and but every single person is
somebody around the world that is paid
to watch it and they're also watching
you weird right yeah and where's the
comic performing at a real club nope
just in this little studio place how are
you supposed to do stand-up when you
don't have you can't hear the laughter
when you're wearing that thing and
you're in there wearing it to you are
when you're doing your set you're
wearing it and you see the audience and
you hear the laughter and they're
watching you do it what and then the
next comic puts it on an as is that I
don't know about that oh no no that
seems weird crazy though right no cuz
it's like at any point it's like uh how
many people are watching oh yeah i got
like 2433 people 900 are paying
attention the other ones like 500 don't
speak English like it also talked about
walking a room you're like oh 500 people
just walked out yeah you got your little
meter and let in the corner and that the
numbers are that's just gonna be comics
taking their dick out that will lead to
comics getting naked immediate oh unlike
the comedy store stage which yeah we
know that never happens yeah so now man
it's like now you you you know I you
know you discard all this material kind
of and it's you know in it but it feels
good to kind of like alright cool man i
can start working on like it forces you
to start another hour yeah it'll
probably be about once all is said and
done it'll be about 50 minutes fifty uh
huh yeah it's about what it'll come down
you know the first show I did a little
over I did about right at an hour and in
the second show I did like an hour 20
yeah um because i just added no more
stories and stuff like that when I uh I
think I told you this bount I know if I
told kev so right after the cut and adds
a little like jump off point of the
elements like the first thing I kind of
talked about so spoiler alert here but
right after Cubs win the World Series
i'm right by zanies the downtown one
yeah and then we jumped on the red line
right after they won as did everybody
this and then went to Wrigley Field and
then when you got off the train there's
like a hundred thousand people on the
street at one in the morning just going
crazy
and everybody smashed and my buddy's
wife is like I'm gonna go dancing we
should go dancing whatever and you know
me and him are like killing you do that
bad so we go to this other bar now
there's nowhere you could pee you know
you couldn't just like piss in a bush
like you normally would if you're dying
the [ __ ] pissed because there's a
million people in the street so I'm like
dude let's let her go dancing because
I'm top 200 pisses I've ever had to take
it was happening to me right now so we
go to this button he's like all these
people dancing here let's go to this bar
so we go in there he goes to the bar she
goes to the dance floor I go to the
bathroom and I right when I pushed its
where do I was it true right when I walk
in the bathroom there's two dudes in the
bathroom and one dude sucking the other
dudes dick beautiful right when I walk
in and I had to pee so bad that I just
look at them and they like look at me
like they're caught and I just go
gentlemen and then I'm just pissed do
you think that was a losing bet that's
exactly what I was gonna say yes then I
go back to the bar and I've seen my
buddy Johnny and I go hey man just you
know I think we're in a gay bar and he
goes what makes you say the helical
trust female we're than a gay bar or the
weirdest bed is being paid off right now
I bro dude you said in 97 I every ever
just got a [ __ ] from a Cardinals fan
fell pretty [ __ ] good that was a
warmest mouth I've ever um do you tell
tea but why we're at why we had him on
what said were yeah we're gonna first of
all if Jerry's jumping out of the
bathroom or he's summer I'm no he's not
gonna [ __ ] be here and then he had to
cancel out yeah but we that true yeah he
was oh that was really various um if I
walked in and he was sitting here out of
just gone nope to the left that's funny
um welcome to my pocket here both of you
have you know you have this like fake
sort of battle like he's the legacy
yesterday's I've since I know yours no
you're a how you're running away so we
wanted to have both of you on at the
same time because of that and you have
your album coming out like a week and a
half or whatever so we wanted you to
promote that and this is the last
episode of our podcast really yeah no
way guys this is last episode of my
pocket
you it's yours whatever shall I do why
why why it's the t even his that's it
yeah it even is to dip [ __ ] buddies
podcast now so you have to figure out
what to do with it from now he's gonna
give you the RSS feed whatever number
and you wanted it you have it I'll just
come over next week yeah yeah see you
then what so why you got what's with the
go bye-byes while we've done a hundred
and eighty three numbers wise but
there's a few more like unnumbered
whatever I give it to like a two hundred
and then nice because it's like what I
mean there's no that's just a number
like 185 or 200 or whatever so we've
done like say 180 185 episodes mm-hmm
and we've just done every sort of angle
on everything we've wanted to do from
the start we were like let's talk about
music and art and style and all the
things we kind of like Netflix and we
sure yet uh and have our friends on that
we like into [ __ ] Radiohead podcast
so this kinda whatever and it we did and
then people you know have listened and
they liked it and we like doing it and
we're at a point now were like we kinda
have talked about all the stuff we've
done everything doesn't want it reflects
from so many different angles and we're
like should we just end it before we
just get like lazy and shitty about it
or just kind of start doing them
intermittently and it kind of fades away
or just give ended on our terms and kind
of be like we're not so you're doing the
opposite of punch drunk that's hilarious
um is it right is it next really funny
what are you doing what I've wanted to
do for the last 11 months yes so I mean
cuz we're we look at it and were like
you know we like doing this and it's
like it's a it didn't turn into like you
know one of the top 20 podcasts on
iTunes where we have whatever [ __ ]
150 thousand downloads an episode if
that was the case would be like all
right we can't just be like by but we
realize like it doesn't everything has
to end it's like you know no like do you
do it forever yeah and we're like I hope
not like pick us up at 180 or like 400
like you know I think after a while sick
what you know there's no difference
between 185 200 no 2 207 153 who gives
you know really cares like we didn't you
know do eight episodes then quit you
know we've given this for three years
I've loved it every time I've done it
every time I've listened to it I've
loved this pocket yeah every we've never
missed a week no nervous a day um and
we're like we'll just like any let's say
there's a good band that like quits when
it's about time or something yeah you
never like how dare you or like you know
anything like that you look yeah well
God now really wish Gary could have been
here yeah anyone in gray ideally you
want to see people go like all come on
but not you know it's better than like
uh that ended okay they were like
finally or something you know yeah you
know you want it were an awesome I
really respect that I mean it would have
been cool had he been here because he
could have been like you guys and then
like the greatest guests and then Jerry
yeah well that's great man will
congratulate like every like people that
were like who's done it a bunch who to
who to the listeners really like and who
do we really always like yeah so
obviously you and Jerry and Leslie
couldn't I don't think was able to zoom
in hard harder than nail down um but and
we're like how do we get all three of
you guys at once so guys have a well
don't mean let's reminisce on them 183
or whatever do you guys have like a
favorite what would you have episodes
that stand out in your head you're like
man that one I remember all the
radiohead ones any of the food testing
ones yeah I liked foods are good though
the denim one yeah does a while back I
remember that I learned a lot from you
guys podcast knows all jokes aside like
you guys a lot of different days ago I
didn't know you know i mean my friend
Brett that's my yeah house important one
I gotta figure out a way to like make us
all I think I might actually try to make
that into a vinyl which would be Brett's
episode oh yeah because I don't know
what we're do podcasts go when they
stopped and I like a 7 I want to make
sure people can still hear it so I
thought it'd be cool to make like a few
hundred copies of it on vinyl it gives
everybody yeah I mean though the podcast
well it'll still be like on iTunes
so as long as all things comedies there
right like it's gonna stay there yeah um
but uh that one was good i like the
geoff mcfetridge one a lot yeah cool he
was so hard to get yeah it was a hard
one at templeton be any advertiser is
[ __ ] great yeah yeah that one got
like a lot of but yeah like that's cool
to hear that you like learn oh
absolutely man did now do you guys have
any one that like stands are you like
that was a nightmare no no there were no
nightmares because we didn't have anyone
on that we didn't want to have on which
was kind of nice that cuz we were doing
a comedy podcast where it's like we had
a like a little run where we were just
having a bunch of comics on and then we
I don't speak for you but I I was like I
don't want to have comics on just to
have month cuz sometimes it can kind of
be worried yeah it can be boring this it
not that they're not funny but boring in
the sense of like if people are tuning
in to be like hey like cool new [ __ ]
about music and art and fashion and she
like that and it's just like
bullshitting mmm you know it's not
really interesting and I could see that
those ones were not listen to as much
but if we had like a very specific
episode but something theme we came up
with yeah or we had like you on we
talked about let's just do an all
Radiohead thing like a something about
raw denim more people would listen to
that which is kind of cool but so after
a hundred and eighty three of those like
how much more we were realizing can we
talk about our favorite bands like how
much more Radiohead and to land like
metal and and in indie rock and like art
in and style and denim and all in the
[ __ ] how much more can we talk about
that before it's like yeah we know you
know which one of you two how did that
conversation come up or you like do it
out dude we were and then you're like
you know what I'm feeling the same way
how did that even topic even come up
asking for a friend it was uh it was a
couple it wasn't long ago now there's a
couple weeks ago and it's the end of a
year sickies have those thoughts anyway
now you're like suicide so what are we
doing now what like you know so we've
been it because we're trying to figure
out like uh let's get a couple in the
bank because he's
on vacation yeah and were like uh I
brought it up I was like so what should
we do cuz and next year's gonna start
and what's like the outlook and stuff
and we just kind of had like a what you
know how how do we feel about this what
have we done how you know do we want to
keep going because obviously we can it's
not like anyone sure yeah yeah you know
not to we could easily go for [ __ ]
we're doing five a week ago rules and
that's another reason why so we kind of
both were like yeah why don't we um why
don't we end it like now before we hate
doing it yeah I would we because again
there's no one's over our head saying we
have to be here so why keep doing
something you know until we [ __ ] as
its first announcement of it if you do
then yeah your fans you know when they
hear it yeah yeah this is it so we got
it I guess recorded intro with now that
you know because I didn't want to tell
you to like at the beginning of episode
familiar I really do want you to talk
about your album yeah yeah yeah cuz it's
gonna come out a week people will be
listening to this as it's coming out
right before now is there any part of
this we're like my album coming out has
killed your podcast I don't want to have
that on my blood on my hands was a title
of the episode as teeps new album and
did occasionally on and ended
occasionally awesome feel really bad
about that right my intention was to end
another podcast with my own yeah you
hear that Ari so by how cool is it to
have re bout billboard right above his
right Hartman Oh funny it's great place
where he was just like bolster rapping
making three dollars an hour day is rent
ready to kill himself I got all the
cheap steak like okay that's only about
to be evicted yeah getting his heart
broken and getting his heart ripped out
of his chest by comedy and women and
other commendable was a good Cody woman
and I think exactly and and now his
giant bill by took a picture of it when
I was heading to do that boys out there
that this is head look
oh I still legit I'm really hope he
fails you know now will only text me
back and I know he does it because I
teased him about it on the show but I'll
like hey are you gonna be on skype this
week you know the kind of map out the
week's show or whatever and he won't
even text me back yes or no or anything
I every text i get from him is either a
why or an N cuz he has that stupid phone
I know I know so then then I'm gonna
hate you in this week and he text me
back why and I text him back no matter
how successful you get it warms my heart
to know that you are still a total dump
lock yeah he's now legitimately
worthless is a piece of [ __ ] got budget
because he gave me as a falcon uh season
seats cleaned with me on and I went but
yeah so it's over uh Wow how'd you guys
feel nostalgic about this you feel like
I'm glad I know freed up another three
hours of my wife I feel just like I'm
glad it didn't get to where it bothered
me like I don't have to feel like oh
you're gonna like Barry Sanders window
yeah just like like no kill it and then
Nick can go do a different podcasts and
I can do whatever I don't you know I
don't know that you got out why they've
you have any other like maybe like later
in the year or do you have any other
ideas like I think I'm gonna start a
different podcast with a definitely
gonna start a different podcast I'm not
going to not have one but do you have
any not gonna like I don't it's not
gonna be like and the week after next
it's my new pocket you know but like I'm
going to start one do already have ideas
for it or any kind of like um what if it
was just all about like farm subsidies
phimosis bucket Dow Jones um the Farmers
Almanac 1915 like wow wow I'm just
reading from it I r arrive in my hidden
podcasting patches wait fireside chats
finally my truth yeah um it's just gonna
be a podcast about like transistors uh
it's called watching grass grow interest
in and there's no video i just talked
about yeah like I think it's I think I
noticed no that was a wind and watch
things and you know that was funny but
you don't tell them what
watching you should do in a podcast
called no spoiler alerts but it's all
spoilers that's what I've been doing on
it makes people your ass on punch drunk
yeah and but I do it now first time I
did it thought we were talking about uh
Tripoli just saw stranger things and
he's like you like I'm talking about
like two weeks ago yeah like that
everybody's already blown through he's
talking about it and Mike he finished it
yeah yeah he was done with it and I oh
yeah it was really good I mean no
spoiler alert eleven dies at the end but
I think there's going to be more than 11
because the names elevenses got to be a
12th person he's putting the thing you
know I totally give the whole end of it
away right and everybody on the show was
like oh you I can't believe you just
[ __ ] did that so then because so many
people hit me on twitter the next day
enraged right the next week I spoil
alerted the season finale of Westworld
whole thing but I you have to be real
tricky about it because you can't go you
know it spoil alert because they know
you're going to do it yeah so when we
were doing our dates we're going to be
I'll be like oh and this week oh one
more gig i'll be at spoiler alerts where
at the end of Westworld Soviets spoiler
alert yeah and I was so tempted when we
first sat down I thought about it my
uber ride over here that i was going to
spoiler alert a arrival but then you
said you hadn't seen it yet now I don't
do it to him but if all three of us had
seen it I was totally gonna do that
those that was the game continued like
not haven't seen that yet know that I
feel like the rules with TV like
spoiling have loosened a little bit
because like you can even go on the
internet now yeah the night of a show
because publications have already
written articles about how what happened
I will tweet about it is like you just
you should know better now than to tune
into a podcast or get on twitter if you
have a show that you love so much it
can't be spoil I don't what game of
thrones or whatever was on I'd be like
I'm not getting anywhere [ __ ] near
fade you know what's even worse is like
if you're like if I have a gig and
there's like a UFC that I want to watch
or a boxing man LD TRL yeah I can't look
at anything yeah yeah you kiss it that's
a great example is P it's been like that
with sports for well like all what a
knock
I'm like god damn it yeah goddamn it you
stay the [ __ ] away from someone's
getting knocked out you know I mean or
whatever yeah when it comes to that you
can't even look at anything at all I'm
almost finished with threes company and
I could I see Twitter you should shit's
gonna give away yo jack moving out
three's a crowd Jack murder Riza what
three when I was um when I was back
Roper's so when I went home to do my
album and then I did that and then I had
like five days where I just kind of like
did like a visit all my friends and
family and everyone stayed with
everybody that finger my mom and your
understanding it's a long whirlwind tour
but so I'm watching like late-night
television like you know wfld or
whatever Chicago station like little
late-night [ __ ] the ropers was on
Wow off only one season the spin-off uh
yeah Norman fell yep begged to not do
the spin-off beg really yeah they were
like we're gonna give you spin up he was
like please don't yeah this is a hit
please don't make me leave a hit and by
the way what's the who's the guy that's
in it that you know the protagonist in a
bald guy different amber amber yeah he
has been I just saw him in like maybe a
twilight zone episodes of like in every
so a jealous yeah like heels you will
notice a look closely at forever the
signing of the Declaration of
Independence yeah yeah with it all like
yeah Lando Calrissian where's been at it
hola yeah yeah man talk about a long
career yeah no but Norman fell was like
please don't do this to us we're on a
hit show and they're like no you're
gonna you're gonna have your own hit
show and they basically kind of force
them and it was gone the season they
couldn't go back oh it was horrible yeah
and because yeah how long can you run
the one gag yeah that they're in this
loveless marriage and then each episode
he proves they're working on fire Don
Knotts not after how great he was to him
would have done that's the best oh
forget it just the best I mean I miss
jack off the thing at the end of his
career where and he was just great and
be so fun for him to do that did I have
one of his eye
how many albums really yeah I found it
on a vinyl like I was just leaving
through records and seven Isles like Don
Knotts did a stand-up album and it was
three dollars how well is it funny
here's the thing i've only listened to a
couple tracks because i can only listen
to it once for the first time what and i
was i had this weird as i kinda wanna
listen to the whole thing right now so
listen like one of the tracks and it was
like kind of funny I was like I could
see this like being good but I'm like
saving it i don't know why i know i
mention this no sense i mentioned this
on my podcast he managed to dip chip
friends which is ending apparently but
he used to be a ventriloquist Oh real
and then he in his biography talks about
that before he did comedy would stand up
and then before he's got into acting he
was a ventriloquist on cruise ships and
amid like Cruz quit in the middle of he
hated it so much and he said he threw
the dummy overboard and he said in his
head he could hear it drown that great
that's so funny yeah it's really I
figure the name of the book may live
here fascinating that's sort of like I
mean an incredible incredible mr. limpet
he like fall it turns into a fish like
to falls into the you know water into a
fish yeah I like to hear it that's how
it tied he was yeah just as I could just
that there's gotta be something better
than this entertaining these drug dumb
drunk [ __ ] yes stupid [ __ ] doll yeah
I know I'm funnier than this he's really
funny I timing everything's great one of
the bits on that was him talking to a
psychiatrist you know it was really I
was like Don Knotts is just a funny
[ __ ] dude it's cool to hear him in
that setting sometimes just naturally
funny oh yeah and maybe if I'd never
find the right vehicle because it david
alan grier like that yeah every time I'm
around that guy oh fun really fun he's
so funny all the time that I have to
like stifle my laughter to not feel like
a Dora yeah but he's just like you're so
funny all the time it's natural but
whether its natural or he just has it is
a master's crazy skill but he's also
like such a skilled performers been
nominated for Tony's like the guys like
just so legit yeah but like you just
like got everything you do I find
interesting mmm but like I and there
hasn't been like a vehicle for Oh
him he's in shows he's always good for
like no you need a show someone make you
the rich he's hilarious in boomerang
dude he's [ __ ] hilarious every time he
doesn t which is the movie I haven't
seen in a long time it was just on the
other day I was like I forgot this movie
yeah with mother uh that was like a
breakout movie for what's who's the hot
chick that's in that not Halle Berry yep
Halle Berry those like a breakout movie
Eddie Murphy wrote that and Eddie Murphy
wears more makeup than every woman in
that movie that's really funny like
there's an end scene when they find like
he comes to her school and I kind of
make up he's wearing so much makeup that
it looks that he looks the years like do
nobody knows this and nobody in this no
nobody knows how much makeup has on
right now it looks crazy hmm I've never
heard anything good about him any my
have privately I have really yeah yeah I
know people that have been around and
they say he's nice he's just you know
he's introverted kind of bizarre bazaar
famous where his life is super super
weird and so he's gotten a little weird
cuz he's been tech has been famous for
40 years yep I mean I mean 19 it's like
it was from a young age jazz 19 he was
bleep I can't get his faint you can't
get any bigger than that dude at one
point and then he's a [ __ ] absolutely
you know and one of the most talented
humans of all time yep like you gotta
put like Eddie Murphy goes into the
pantheon with like Chaplin and people
like that sure like Jerry Lewis darling
change stand up in a lot of ways because
there's not a comic of our generation or
or above are 45 didn't if you're
anywhere from yeah 35 to 50 yeah you
probably still have fifty percent of
delirious memorized yeah never saw God
you've never seen anything is gonna I'm
just gonna never you get so mad I get so
mad will be talking about something I
like quote like Caddyshack or I'll quote
like stripes alter the class anything
it's just like a handful of like classic
eighties movies is because I didn't
[ __ ] I was like two years old in the
eighties and by time as a teenager I was
like this is old eighties movies
whatever and then I'd watch like more
stuff that was like really weird science
it yeah
I saw that when I was a kid but I was
just like yeah it's fine like Ferris
Bueller's Day is a day off I've seen
[ __ ] 20 times must see my weird
science stationary um oh do you have it
where I'm against the wall against the
window oh yeah nice weird i said that
that's crazy yeah i saw that was on the
other day i was like oh [ __ ] forgot
about this movie no I what year did that
come out samia's Purple Rain I love
where it's a great year for movies I
tell you I met the guy who did the
Purple Rain type at a wedding yeah crazy
j vy gan that's such a weirdo so many
people in that world and it's a world
that unless you know it exists you don't
even think about it I did I'd it like I
when I looked at my was like wait you do
the [ __ ] purple rain type and then it
told you his wife to the van yeah mmhmm
yeah the two of them just must be what
the hell man they must have argued for
like two years about their wedding
invitation this keeps one are each other
it's like the hand on a bat to the most
normal people you've ever just like you
get Tom Petty covers like so I'm looking
up all that all the street the homepage
off of your episodes yeah can get those
words out that's why why this is ending
yeah I can't think of things um Kevin
gets drunk is one that a lot of people
oh oh yeah that's what I was going to
ask you guys what was your most popular
episode Templeton it's all long yeah by
Omega the most popular um and then I the
first time re was on oh that's probably
Bobby Lee and steven is easy those are
up there that's a shame yeah um and then
Brenna's easy is always a great podcast
guess we've made him throw up three
times in three different studios that's
really fun and then we lock the door
when he tries to run out I will lock it
and then not tell him that it's locked
and then he tries to run away but you're
like we always plan to be really good at
getting out of buildings fast too shabby
see you should do have your own pot on
this guy
a dead robot dings whoo yeah that that
was I've never seen Star Wars oh by the
way I know what I've heard I was at this
production company before I came here
and a couple of them went to a screening
of it of rogue one and said it's the
best of all 60 and I go do that is a
bold statement what everyone says about
every new Star Wars is he passed thus
far to this guy's credit he's he hated
the last three the three new words the
last one by the way was just fine people
were like it's a but you're like it was
a Star Wars movie those are yeah it was
a Star Wars movie yeah I wouldn't hit
all the viet bullet points like we're
gonna make a Star Wars movie here's all
the Star Wars things we have to have in
the Star Wars movie like to see anon
death star star wars movie happen
sometime in the next five years yeah
yeah maybe this one's cool because it's
not like you know it doesn't like talk
about all the central characters and
apparently it's like seven and a half
hours long nice but uh seven no they
were like I was legitimately like and I
was like that's a bold statement I'm
like how trustworthy are you like with
it I mean he goes why I didn't like the
last he was I like the last one but I'd
hated the other three I'm ready I want
to I want to see it yeah I go see it
this weekend spoiler Darth Vader dies in
the end oh we had max max from Eve 6 on
that was really cool oh i was gonna
what's your least favorite episode ah no
idea you know without like insulting a
guest doesn't mean it was necessarily
their fault I don't I not one doesn't
stand out really never had a full-on
disaster we're just like that sucked
yeah because we never had on like
strangers and even the people we didn't
know they were they were interesting
yeah we the subject matter was Lucy a
full-on disaster turn into punch-drunk
Sports live every Tuesday name the two
uh having a Greg Rivera that the guy who
owns Mishka that was as cool Mishka yeah
to follow the label oh yeah cuz she
started it from the ground up and just
hearing about all that was like really
really cool that was episode 56 yeah you
guys did so
many good like um like I said I really
learned a lot from it like a lot of like
that not human inches but something like
that we like oh my how do you really
think about it all much work goes into
you know yeah my friend you know who
served keep shoe company saying like
that the kind of thing you don't know
anything about like how do you [ __ ]
do this yeah how the [ __ ] to sort of
shoot [ __ ] yeah when do I still work at
when I used to manage that screen
printing shop uh how many phone calls a
day do you think I took from a person
that goes hey man I want to start my own
shirt line and I have my own designs and
just cut me a break and then it's like
Mike good first of all you're totally
going to fail because 99 if you think
you're the first person as first of all
there's an industry that you just went
through 12 different phone numbers in
the yellow pages right of an industry
that exists because people like you have
this idea by the way eighty percent of
those guys before they contact you
contact me oh hey man have you ever
thought due to t-shirt like oh no we
meant do you mean like putting designs
on shirts holy [ __ ] no one's ever done
that let me ask you this will they end
up in my garage right I am land like
giving 50 to the goodwill yes please
will they be wearing these in Africa yes
you know like the losing Super Bowl team
yeah it's like the opposite land their
Buffalo Bills Super Bowl Championship
yeah like a we did a bunch of field trip
ones that were cool we went to the Kitty
Hello Kitty con catcon also catcon yeah
we went to it we saw a concert did one
of that by the way what's going to a
morrissey convention or capsid on that
there's cats and kittens and people it's
all just cat people have a convention
about cat related stuff it was weird was
it also we had that one of the most
famous internet cats called pudge the
cat we had that Japanese cat the world
around smushed up there not that
different one I love that guy yeah this
one's like right on that level uh-huh we
had a cat has more followers in there
and get rid of this it has a manager we
had the manager so we had the manager on
and were like tell us what if I thought
you were taller got really this morning
what does he do
how much is that what does he make it
was a her capiam it was a her and she
wouldn't get super specific about money
yeah yeah but she the cat has an owner
obviously she works with the owner it
makes it does appearances yep yeah I
mean it because it's like such a cute
cat so cute yeah its name is Sheila
Dikshit attach the cabbage the cat was
Instagram let me look this [ __ ]
up yeah while we're talking about this
because I got to see what a cat looks
like that has a goddamn man have a
manager the Brett kill row episode was
number 82 for those of you who want to
check that out if you haven't and yeah
we talk about interesting stuff you guys
should print some t-shirts with a like a
headstone and then like the day like all
IP and then the dates we did was your
debut episode was the date of that I
should know since it's my paw but I you
know I do so many prawns it was it
doesn't say that day but it was three
years ago would have been a Tuesday now
here's a problem for all that's Pudge
there's also a pledge the fit well we
released three at once though all right
yeah we didn't want to have just want
you know it's kind of a dude um but uh
but yeah I mean and to be honestly when
you do a hundred and eighty whatever you
forget a lie I'm scrolling through this
one I'm like wait we did what was this
one about yeah I can't even remember
what our podcast was last Tuesday we did
one on the re a disc a twenty eight
twenty years of juxtapose the magazine
oh yeah that was a cool one that's
really informative uh base we did
something that and then like the ones
about uh like stuff in our lives we're
kind of cool to do yeah we like people
who like we're influences to oh yeah you
like yeah just like in more
introspective ones we're kind of fun to
do yeah um yeah this Pudge the cats
pretty cute I don't know if he's a
manager worthy cute that's funny our
desert island playlist which took us
[ __ ] forever to do i took a six
months to be like okay i have i've been
on that i had some familiar no I just
talked to you about it about oh that's
right like the five songs that we could
take with us like when we would have
Brendan on because you would go so hard
at his list oh yeah Brendan Brendan
Smith is was a really good guess all the
ones he's done uh yeah we had a couple
authors oh yeah I I put my first album
on there for free is a bonus episode may
be other those girls episode between 111
112 we did a bunch of recommending stuff
episodes which people respond well to
things we just think are cool yeah okay
what we're saying is you got enough
listeners yeah exactly so like yeah not
even in a shitty way but it's like you
get to a point really like we don't like
after a hundred eighty three episodes
like there's not that much new stuff for
like into like music wise or style only
moved so fast and we're not like we're
not 23 is we're constantly getting end
up honestly I'm literally sick of myself
so r area I like yeah might the sound of
my own voice is started to grade on my
heart yeah Oh Robin O'Neill the artist
oh [ __ ] art I'm obsessed with her news
of his [ __ ] every time I see a
[ __ ] picture I you should hiding her
I text her go I love that more than the
last day a she's killing it I want to
look at it in real life but she has a
showing in like Dallas oh I can't see it
there yeah you know you guys are so
talented you guys think that you might
maybe like do like a reunion episode or
even entertain the idea of a hologram
episode haha so stupid no a hologram the
hologram pod casts such as a hologram of
you guys hala cast yeah the hunter pad
be very careful as a bad name yeah oh
you know who's fun have on Colin Hanks
oh yeah oh I bet of course Power has now
is a popular episode great dark it was
yeah yeah really a document a really
good guy ah the author of The Comedians
which if you haven't read that book read
that book read history of comedy yep
cliff nesterov because of you oh yeah
cuz of the pot yeah um cuz of this
podcast I actually read a book yeah we
did a bunch of like style fashion
recommendations will fall winter of for
every every year we just did one of
those for fall
yeah I mean we basically just did all
the [ __ ] we wanted to do we talked about
all talked about danman Radiohead which
was literally the point of our Casa
starting at that was the yeah yeah that
was the no.1 [ __ ] sandwiches you know
we're just like a love sandwiches we
talk about a lot we're doing an episode
uh wow that's crazy in this front humans
in rock I forgot we did that one what is
it that's a great one men best front
humans in rock episode 139 we just like
favorite front people and music I feel
like that's a lost our Freddie Mercury
Freddie Mercury absolutely yeah Karen oh
and we just be gay they have to be in a
band otherwise it's changed yeah it's
hard even to say like purchased and
printed Michael Jackson and no one can
beat any of those guys so like they had
to be in bands because Robinson is a
great frontman yeah great frontman man i
would put him in my top five Chrissie
Hynde I would absolutely put Freddie
Mercury and we did a desert island worst
five awful songs we didn't want whoo
give me like a taste of like what each
one of a couple of years my time
remember stairway to heaven Oh anything
that I'm so sick of here it was just
like repetitive 90s [ __ ] or something
yeah be like no I'll just listen to the
wind thank you all right but you haven't
heard a human poison I said the wind
yeah we did we started doing some
playlist ones that you did one of those
yeah which are those are fun to do boo
boo um so yeah I mean we covered a lot
of stuff that we were just into and if
you're sad to see it go thanks for
listening to every episode that you SAT
and listened to you if you haven't like
go but this stuff I don't remember
recording so you didn't uh listen go
back and we're buying the t-shirt if you
buy wanted you know [ __ ] collector's
item where it is 10 million dollars yeah
he bought one from boom shakalaka for to
get a bunch of shirdi i know everybody
that's the second time he's had one
because i remember seeing what i was
looking to i'm like like weird were you
getting these I found it yeah Michael
worry about it kid now I'm like
tebow did he give you any literally said
no he didn't I'm like you just telling
me that stole a [ __ ] [ __ ] Sam
Tripoli lyptus car unlocked is what
happened probably something like that or
like because it wasn't our printer will
mail ah all of our proofs there from for
us to approve just sends them to the
store yeah so it must have been like
sitting in the office or something or
sitting somewhere look you guys seen
Danny by lack weight gradually hurts so
the initial paragraph the description
for the podcast we very first started it
we're too young little boy it was join
these two la natives as they interview
their comedian actor artist and
degenerate friends in search of the
parts of life that are occasionally
awesome also they talk about jeans and
radiohead a lot really yeah that was
literally the biggest needed a
description we're like for now this is
what it is they kind of like stuck to
that we didn't really have way I mean we
had a good amount of comedians on but
for our three the three of ours you know
it's like Sam's got this like super long
bio about like all the greatest gigs
he's ever done I already got all these
like TV credits and movie credits and
all this and then mine just says [ __ ]
pants words little love it's like three
paragraphs for each one of them and mine
just says [ __ ] look you sure that's what
I said I'm positive man none of that
[ __ ] means anything to anybody really
yeah i'm gonna read any of this me like
wow what an amazing bio you first of all
amazing by oh yeah we didn't want to
meet with you too we read your bio yeah
it's like give and then what we read it
we all looked at each other and slowly
nod yeah this is the guy tapped our lip
with a pencil this is the guy um yeah
may your tomorrow you're one of our we
have many guests that we really like you
have done it the most so by that
definition you're probably our favorite
guest really having you back on true I
your legs also part of it like you're
also the one that we always knew had
nothing else going on it obviously show
that we I know you're joking but no
there's been times on my hey do the pod
you like I have other podcasts of other
[ __ ] but another reason you are one of
our favorites is because we actually in
real life we have we all have so much in
common yeah and like the podcast is just
[ __ ] were into your indesit were into
yeah so made
made a lot of sense to have you on as
like the last guest and your albums
coming out we wanted to you know / me
that sorry to see this goes always one
of my favorites to do I think that are
you gonna do pot I don't know mmm I
haven't sided out Simon think about for
a while yet not for a while and then you
like a while while two years like a
while maybe two years because you I
don't want to rush into one cuz the real
commitment do you do 14 years yeah so
like I decide to dad the worst thing to
do is to be like TIFF rush yourself into
one and then be lazy about it and do an
episode every four weeks and this one
knows a listen to it like I've been in a
relationship like you kind of want to be
single for a little bit before you get
back at one cuz you have to show up and
do it yeah you know yeah and then you
know I don't want it to be dink yeah now
so I don't know I may not who knows
we'll see yeah and there's no [ __ ]
it's only there's no no one's waiting
for it there's no rule is no no one
there's no demand for me to do another
one so [ __ ] it yeah there I mean there's
just no rules you do when ideas yeah I
think once my album comes out I'm gonna
do I'm gonna do one like a solo one yeah
why not yeah I think I've really want to
yeah dude you should I mean why not yeah
you should you have a lot of like your
brain works in so many different in
interesting ways you know you're not let
just like thinking that's why you're
such a great podcast guy so you can talk
about tons of [ __ ] and like a most of
its lies and I just make sure yeah yeah
that's fine too love my new podcast
occasionally awesome we'll be out pretty
soon ah that name is actually very
available it sounds like it is not
expensive yeah only 10 million dollars
like the shirts you guys take a post
dated jack yeah no we totally will yeah
2070 looks to be your oh by the way I'm
watching that a butcher named Leah
Remini your remedy remedy um X I
intelligence the hallways yeah i'm
watching that I've been watching that
for uh you know you sign contracts with
them you know how long the contracts are
billion years a billion years yes Percy
org it says it on I did the tour years
ago and it does a plaque on the wall
we're reading and again I might have to
do a son your eternal soul over for 1
billion years
that sort of laugh at each other and
this employee kind of like looks and
sees 11th like that no it's ensues I
want to go over there Dennis I'm
billions a good I'm gonna walk into that
place and then go to like the front desk
me oh yeah um I'm here to fight anybody
yeah I'm sorry you what yes I'm looking
to fistfight any one of you that wants
to fight right now where is the
Department of fisticuffs that's gonna be
the head of the department of fisticuffs
yeah thank you everybody we love you
yeah I'm sorry to the people who will
miss it Haley yeah hailey a lot one of
our biggest fans will shout you out by
name yet it did yeah you should like
couple guys have to have certain fans of
judges like Swiffer in be devastated by
the way problem what's funny to is
sometime like I want to sit there do
that but I'm like a lot of them are user
names and like they're hard to remember
yep blip blop 6565 we've been the best
yeah but which is why I made it a point
to always respond to people it's um I'm
not gonna be able to remember name but
everyone I've actually ever emailed with
or tweeted back at or with anyone has
ever said something nice and stuff or
sent recommendations of your own or told
me where to go eat and do [ __ ] in
different cities one on the road thanks
to all you guys too for listening and
being supportive and stuff and buying
shirts and buying [ __ ] my albums and
buying the pins that I made a pin that I
made um and yeah and like showing your
support because this was a [ __ ] free
podcast for free yep don't I know it you
know I mean yeah I mean they're just
like a thing you do because you like to
do them so the fact that people listened
a lot and were like interactive with and
all your fans have always been super
super cool to me it's any of them to it
you have ever reached out or ever said
hey I loved that episode or you know get
those guys off that show and take it
over I really haha boys appreciated sure
our fans are super nice that's why we
return wait you guys had private lessons
yeah that's all we're gonna let them
laying them down yeah we're letting what
I do to everyone who cares about me so
for all of your fans to reach out to
Jerry and two things let him know man
was we can never win and I said we blame
him for the end of the pot had he been
here tonight he probably could have
talked you guys into sticking around but
now are we handle what we're like if
people can't even show up to the last
episode yeah why do anymore exactly that
seal the deal this wasn't gonna be the
last one until that if someone's like
I'm on my deathbed come say goodbye and
they were like house next week I'm gonna
be dead yeah I'd love to come but I've
got a beautiful fiance in a private jet
yeah not me Jerry I'm sleeping in the
bushes outside the night hoping there's
another episode in oh god that's so
[ __ ] funny I think that I think I was
like a little bummed out when I was like
cuz i went to get i stopped and got
coffee and i was doing the thing I do on
my way to come here I was like yeah I do
this once a week and I'm not gonna yeah
because I'll stopping coffee think about
what we're gonna talk about in the ass
than this and that and then I was like
oh yeah and then I'm always like either
gonna be five minutes earlier seven
minutes late have you got to be there
have you thought about like where you're
gonna do yours or when you're anything
about it at all there any kind of
teasers give any of your fans about it
or don't know I mean what you all know
is i will like when I have an idea for
one and have recorded some episodes i
will post about it on Instagram and
Twitter and like i'll link it all right
a little like blog about on my website
bill yes my new podcast please listen
and we're because i won't be able to
promote it on this pod get you know it
which is kind of a weird thing because
everyone someone like oh yeah i'm doing
the show or at this get all like tell
people on the podcast about it and now
i'm gonna be like oh I won't be able to
but I mean that's and that's another
reason why I'm gonna want to start a new
one because I'm gonna want like you know
that I'll led to be able to let me show
and on about whatever the podcast will
be about it goes without saying any time
either one of you guys want to come by
and DuPont trunk I'm oh you guys always
welcome anything you guys want to
promote when I commit suicide it'll be
on NICs Instagram and this is a video
that I'm I remember posted oh my god
yeah heaven is that
so is that wow that was occasionally
also yeah how did he get access to my
phone I don't even remember Wow uh II
ultimate [ __ ] bomb oh yeah so um yeah
that's it we're not gonna make it a
whole [ __ ] sad you know like on this
and then that it was like a fun thing to
do for three years we no one told us
what to do during the whole [ __ ]
thing it was that's really a cool thing
about all things comedy they never made
us do anything yeah we were able to do
what we wanted when we wanted to do it
and that's kind of cool because it's
like similarly I mean it's different
than stand up in a way were like you
don't have to like listen to the [ __ ]
cry you have to show up be Leah are the
crowds at this I'm an altar use like
we're doing an episode about this and
that's it exactly want to do it release
it and however it goes it goes you know
a few things are like free is that you
know yeah that's like to give and take
of like okay here's the deal this is yes
it's free yeah so you get no say so
exactly yeah and because it's free I'm
just can do whatever I want yeah and it
might be good sometimes money bad
sometimes but that's just life yeah yeah
that's how life goes yeah you know yeah
and if it's any of you enjoy that why do
it any longer because that's another
part of it too so I'm gonna do it how I
want when I want you know you feel the
same way and then we go like let's just
be done because we want to be yeah you
know yeah that's it and then they'll be
like a new different thing right that's
how you [ __ ] move forward and yeah I
respect that man i respect and i'm all
jokes aside i am honored that you guys
had me on the last one and i'm not
surprised that Jerry didn't show up and
carefully set for the final record like
you I waited last statement it's a good
last statement yeah the episodes called
Jerry doesn't show yeah and the results
the results of Jerry's the consequences
of Jerry's apathy um well that's it you
guys um that's the last episode this is
the last episode of occasionally awesome
bang continue to follow us on Twitter
and Instagram Kevin Kevin gee Christy on
both of those things yep i'm at Nikki
Yousef and I see
kyo us SEF Nikki Yusef com that's where
you will find everything that will be up
to from here on out including uh the
next podcast I do when ever that begins
you will know at those places t um I
will you follow me at the tea banh
Twitter th e te eb and that's the best
way to find out all my gigs and dates
and my album return to the red state
comes out the first week of January on
all things records as well as iTunes and
every other place you can get it and
punch drunk every Tuesday noon to to
live on a YouTube on all things comedy
network that does it get that album
everybody and listen to those podcasts t
to the [ __ ] best dude love you guys
man i love you guys congratulations on
such a great ago think and I was always
my pleasure to be on it awesome we'll
see you on the next thing everybody